[Music]
all systems of oppression are highly
adaptive and they can adapt to
challenges and incorporate them they can
allow for exceptions and I think the
most effective adaptation of the system
of racism to the challenges of the civil
rights movement was to reduce a racist
to a very simple formula a racist is an
individual always an individual not a
system who consciously does not like
people based on race must be conscious
and who intentionally seeks to be mean
to them individual conscious intent and
if that is my definition of a racist
then your suggestion that anything I've
said are done is racist or has a racist
impact I'm gonna hear that as you just
said I was a bad person you just put me
over there in that category and most of
my bias anyway is unconscious so I I'm
not intending I'm not aware so now I'm
gonna need to defend my moral character
and and I will and we've all seen it it
seems to be virtually impossible based
on that definition for the average white
person to look deeply at their
socialization to look at the
inevitability of internalizing racist
biases developing racist patterns and
having investments in the system of
racism which is pretty comfortable for
us and serves us really well I think
that definition of a racist that
either/or what I call the good bad
binary is the root of virtually all
white defensiveness on this topic
because it makes it virtually impossible
to talk to the average white person
about the inevitable absorption of a
racist worldview that we get by being
literally swimming in racist water so
let me connect that to myself as a
result of being raised as a white person
in this society I have a racist
worldview
I have a deep racist biases I have
developed racist patterns and I have
investments in the system of racism
because it's it served me really well
it's comfortable it's helped me
overcome the the barriers that I do face
and I also have an investment of not
seeing any of that for what it would
suggest to me about my identity and what
it would require of me right I didn't
choose any of that I don't feel guilty
about it it is an inevitable result of
being raised in this society in which
racism is the bedrock the question of
guilt comes in in what am i doing about
that while we who are white tend to be
fragile in that it doesn't take much to
upset us around race the impact of our
response is not fragile at all it's a
kind of weaponized defensiveness
weaponized hurt feelings right and it
functions really really effectively to
repel the challenge and as a white
person I moved through the world
racially comfortable virtually 24/7 it
is exceptional for me to be outside of
my racial comfort zone and most of my
life I've been warned not to go outside
my racial comfort zone and so on the
rare occasion when I am uncomfortable
racially it's it's a kind of throwing
off of my racial equilibrium and I need
to get back into that and so I will do
whatever it takes to repel the challenge
and get back into it and in that way I
think white fragility functions as a
kind of white racial bullying to be
frank we make it so miserable for people
of color to talk to us about our
inevitable and often unaware racist
patterns that we cannot help develop
from being socialized into a culture in
which racism is the bedrock and the
foundation we make it so miserable for
them to talk to us about it that most of
the time they don't write just and we
just have to understand that most people
of color that are working or living in
primarily white environments take home
way more daily slights and hurts and
insults than they bother talking to us
about because they're experiencing
they're going to risk more punishment
they're going to lose the relationship
they're going to have their experience
minimized explained away they're going
to cause the person to feel attacked or
hurt and in that way
white fragility functions as a kind of
everyday white racial control none of
that has to be intentional or conscious
but that is how it functions and it's
actually incredibly liberating and
transformative to start from the premise
that of course I've internalized all of
this and then I can stop defending
deflecting denying hoping you won't
notice
minimizing explaining and I can just let
go of that and get to work
and there's a question that's never
failed me in my efforts to unpack how do
we pull this off how do so many of us
who are white individually feel so free
of racism and yet we live in a society
that is so profoundly separate and
unequal by race and the question that's
never failed me is not is this true or
is this false is this right or is this
wrong but how does it function how do
these narratives that I tell how do they
function when I tell you well I'm just
an individual why can't we all just be
individuals when I tell you I was taught
to treat everyone the same when I tell
you but it's focusing on race that
divides us when I tell you but I have
lots of friends of color those
narratives have not changed our outcome
and they function to take race off the
table and to exempt the person from any
further engagement and in doing that
they function to protect the current
racial hierarchy in the white position
within it it doesn't have to be what I'm
intending to do but it is the impact of
those narratives
[Music]